Tyra:
PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THE GIRLS NOT ONLY LEARNED ABOUT
PARISIAN HAUTE COUTURE.
THEY LEARNED ABOUT PARISIAN MEN.
Shannon: SO THIS IS OUR DINNER?
Man: THIS IS IT.
Adrianne: OKAY.
Tyra: A NUDE PHOTO SHOOT PUSHED
SOME GIRLS TO THEIR LIMITS.
Robin: THIS WEEK, IT'S TWO
STRANDS OF RIBBON AND A THONG.
WHAT IS IT GONNA BE NEXT WEEK?
Tyra: AND ROBIN WAS THE ONE
ASKED TO LEAVE.
NOW ONLY THREE GIRLS REMAIN:
SHANNON, THE ALL-AMERICAN
VIRGIN.
Shannon: I'VE GOT WHAT IT TAKES.
Tyra: ELYSE, THE HIGH-FASHION,
PRE-MED STUDENT.
AND ADRIANNE,
THE ROCK-N-ROLL TOMBOY.
Adrianne: PLUS, I'M FUNNY,
I'M PRETTY.
I GOT PERFECT TEETH.
Tyra: ONE OF THESE GIRLS WILL BE
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
♪♪♪
Elyse: I MISS ROBIN.
(Adrianne laughing)
Adrianne: THAT WAS FUNNY.
I'M REALLY HAPPY ROBIN'S GONE.
I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT I WANT
AND NOT GET
IN TROUBLE FOR IT.
HOW DO YOU LIKE
THESE APPLES, BABY?
HOW DO YOU LIKE 'EM?
Shannon: OH, MY GOSH!
Elyse: ADRIANNE, SHANNON AND
MYSELF LIVING IN THE HOUSE,
I THINK WILL BE PRETTY PLEASANT.
IT'D BE NICE TO SEE MORE OF
SHANNON'S TRUE COLORS
AND SEE HER LET
LOOSE A LITTLE BIT,
WHICH I DON'T THINK SHE DID
AROUND ROBIN.
Elyse: DO THE STOMP, GIRL.
PUT YOUR MONEYMAKER TO WORK.
Adrianne: MY MONEYMAKER.
Shannon: I DO MISS ROBIN.
SHE WAS, LIKE, SORT OF LIKE MY
MOTHER IN THE HOUSE,
BUT I DO FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
ELYSE AND ADRIANNE.
THEY'RE FUN, AND AT LEAST NOW I
CAN BE MORE OUTGOING IN A WAY,
AND I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
LIKE, BEING QUIET ALL THE TIME,
'CAUSE I-- THAT IN A WAY, I WAS
LIKE THAT A LITTLE BIT,
MAYBE WHEN SHE WAS AROUND.
♪♪
Shannon: I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
I'M IN THE FINAL THREE.
Adrianne: AND ALL THOSE PEOPLE
THAT TOLD ME THAT
I WASN'T GONNA MAKE IT TO THE
END CAN JUST...
BECAUSE I'M STILL HERE.
Shannon: YEAH, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO THINK.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
'CAUSE WE'RE ALL, LIKE, BLONDE
HAIR, SHORT HAIR, BROWN HAIR.
Elyse: THE THREE OF US ARE HERE.
I CAN'T EVEN SPECULATE AS TO
WHO'S GONNA BE ELIMINATED.
WE'LL JUST HAVE TO SEE WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO.
Tyra: HELLO.
Adrianne: HI.
Shannon: HEY!
Elyse: HI.
Tyra: WHY IS EVERYBODY MATCHING,
LIKE RED AND ORANGE?
SO, Y'ALL, IT'S GETTING DOWN TO
THE WIRE.
Shannon: I KNOW!
Tyra: WHAT YOU GUYS ARE ABOUT TO
EXPERIENCE RIGHT NOW
IS THE PINNACLE OF AMERICAN
FASHION.
YOU'VE ALREADY EXPERIENCED THE
PINNACLE OF FRENCH FASHION,
WHICH IS HAUTE COUTURE, BUT NEW
YORK FASHION WEEK IS THE TOP,
THE MOST AMAZING THING ABOUT
AMERICAN FASHION.
AND WE'RE GONNA SEE IF YOU GUYS
HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE IN A FASHION SHOW.
Shannon: WOW.
Tyra: I'M GONNA HAVE YOU MEET
DREW LINEHAN,
WHO'S A FASHION SHOW PRODUCER
HERE IN NEW YORK,
AND HE'S GONNA TELL YOU ALL
ABOUT FASHION WEEK.
Y'ALL READY?
YES.
♪♪
Drew: I'M DREW.
I'M SHANNON.
SHANNON, HOW ARE YOU?
ELYSE, NICE TO MEET YOU.
ADRIANNE, NICE TO MEET YOU.
I PRODUCE AND CAST FASHION SHOWS
DURING FASHION WEEK.
IT'S A REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT
TIME FOR YOUR CAREER.
WHEN YOU GO TO THESE SHOWS,
THE PEOPLE IN THE FRONT ROW
ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN FASHION.
IT IS A GRUELING THREE WEEKS.
YOUR HAIR IS BEING RIPPED OUT.
YOUR FEET ARE BEING SHOVED IN
SHOES THAT DON'T FIT.
IT'S TOUGH.
WHEN YOU GO ON A GO SEE,
IT'S A JOB INTERVIEW.
YOU ARE TRYING
TO WIN THE JOB FROM ME.
YOU HAVE TO, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WORK THE CLIENT...
Elyse: WHEN DREW WAS GIVING HIS
BIG LECTURE,
IT WAS REALLY BORING, AND IT WAS
HARD TO PAY ATTENTION,
AND MY EYES WERE GLAZING OVER.
ONE GIRL WAS SORT
OF DOZING OFF, YOU KNOW?
YOU CAN'T DOZE OFF.
I MEAN,
YOU'RE HERE TO SELL YOURSELF.
MAKE SURE YOU SAY, "GOODBYE,"
"THANK YOU" AND "SEE YOU AGAIN."
NICE MEETING YOU ALL.
GOOD LUCK WITH EVERYTHING.
Shannon: THANK YOU,
HAD FUN, THANKS.
Drew: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
NICE MEETING YOU.
Adrianne: VERY NICE MEETING YOU.
Shannon: AND I WILL SEE YOU
AGAIN.
Drew: EXACTLY,
GOOD FOR YOU.
Adrianne: I JUST FEEL LIKE
THROWING YOU AROUND LIKE
A RAG DOLL.
Elyse: WHAT ARE WE DOING?
Adrianne: HAVING OUR TALK
WITH SHANNON.
Elyse: SHANNON, WHEN A MAN AND A
WOMAN
LOVE EACH OTHER VERY MUCH, LIKE
YOUR FATHER AND I...
Shannon: NO!
DO YOU WANT ME TO TEACH
YOU A SELF-DEFENSE MOVE?
Adrianne: SURE.
HEY, BABY!
LIKE HE'S DRUNK AND TRYING TO
PUT HIS ARM AROUND ME LIKE THIS.
I GO LIKE THIS.
WAIT, DON'T DO THAT.
Adrianne: YOUR FINGER IS IN MY
FINGERS.
Shannon: AND I'M LIKE THIS
AND I'M LIKE THIS.
OW, THAT HURTS.
OH, YEAH, BABY!
Elyse: THE MORE I GET TO KNOW
SHANNON, THE MORE I LIKE HER.
I THINK SHE'S REALLY, REALLY
GENUINE.
Adrianne: AND I REALLY ENJOYED
OUR PAST COUPLE OF DAYS TOGETHER
BECAUSE MY EVIL INFLUENCE
HAS BROUGHT OUT THE WORST
IN SHANNON.
Adrianne: STOP!
SHANNON!
(laughing)
Shannon: I THINK I'M MORE MYSELF
NOW BECAUSE
I CAN AT LEAST, UM, BE SORT OF
SILLY AT TIMES.
YOU CAN'T GET ME WHEN I'M
ALREADY DOWN!
♪♪
Shannon: OH, I LIKE THIS HAT.
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS WE'VE
HAD SOME FREE TIME,
SO WE'VE BEEN OUT IN NEW YORK
SHOPPING AROUND.
Shannon: OH, MY WORD,
THIS IS SO COOL.
OH, MY WORD!
I DON'T FEEL
LIKE I'M THE THIRD WHEEL.
NORMALLY, WHEN YOU HAVE THREE
TOGETHER,
ONE FEELS, LIKE, LEFT OUT,
AND I DON'T AT ALL.
THESE TWO GIRLS JUST MAKE ME
FEEL RIGHT AT HOME.
Adrianne:
SHANNON, COME HERE, BABY.
I WON'T LEAVE YOU OUT.
Shannon: THANKS.
♪♪
Shannon: OH, MY GOSH,
WE HAVE MAIL, LADIES.
Adrianne: HAND IT TO ME,
AND I WILL READ IT.
Shannon: "YOU HAVE A FASHION
SHOW CASTING TONIGHT AT 8:00 PM.
"HAVE YOUR HAIR AND MAKEUP DONE,
BE DRESSED AND IN THE HEELS
BY 7:30 PM."
Tyra: GUYS, YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING A GO SEE
WITH BABY PHAT FASHIONS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE YOUR
PERSONAL STYLE
AND INCORPORATE WHAT KIMORA
CALLS THE STOMP,
WHEN YOU SHOW YOUR RUNWAY WALK
AT YOUR AUDITION.
SO I'M GONNA SHOW YOU WHAT IT
IS, ALL RIGHT?
HERE'S A STOMP.
GET TO THE END, AND YOU'RE LIKE,
POW! WHAT? SO? AND?
AND JUST FEEL MY STRIDE AND SEE,
MY HIP IS KIND OF DROPPING.
ELYSE COULD POTENTIALLY
ROCK THE FASHION WORLD.
SHE HAS SUCH A HIGH FASHION
EDITORIAL LOOK.
I MEAN, SHE IS PERFECT FOR HIGH
FASHION,
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF ELYSE REALLY
WANTS THIS ENOUGH.
AND GIRLS THAT ARE AMBIVALENT
ARE USUALLY NOT SUCCESSFUL.
Adrianne: SHE HATES MODELING.
SHE HATES DOING EVERYTHING WE
DO, YET SHE'S THE BEST AT IT.
Tyra: LONGER STRIDES.
SHANNON IS ALL WARM AND FUZZY
AND ALL-AMERICAN.
I MEAN, HER SMILE IS JUST LIKE,
BING!
IN ORDER FOR HER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL
AND TAKE IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL,
SHE'S GONNA HAVE TO BECOME
MORE EDGY, MORE INTERESTING.
AT TIMES I THOUGHT THAT SHANNON
WOULD WIN THE COMPETITION,
BUT SHANNON CHOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE
IN THE LAST PHOTO SHOOT,
AND NOW I THINK THAT
SHE'S ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATED
HERSELF FROM THE COMPETITION.
Tyra: ADRIANNE HAS COME SUCH A
LONG WAY,
AND SHE REALLY WANTS THIS,
BUT SHE'S STILL
SO ROUGH AROUND THE EDGES.
SHE NEEDS A LOT OF POLISHING.
Shannon: WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
ADRIANNE IS THAT
SHE DOESN'T CARE WHAT OTHERS
THINK OF HER.
SHE'S GONNA BE WHO SHE IS NO
MATTER WHAT.
Tyra: I HAVE
NO IDEA WHO'S GONNA WIN.
ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA,
AND I LOVE THAT.
♪♪
Elyse: TODAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
GO-AND-SEE
FOR A CASTING CALL FOR A BABY
PHAT FASHION SHOW.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO THE HOUSE OF BABY PHAT.
I'VE BEEN CASTING ALL DAY,
I'M DOING A FASHION SHOW.
YOU GUYS HAVE
TO GIVE IT ALL YOU GOT,
JUST LIKE THE OTHER HUNDREDS OF
GIRLS WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT.
SO I GUESS WE'RE GONNA TAKE
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE DONE
THUS FAR AND SEE
WHAT YOU GUYS GOT.
ADRIANNE, PLEASE COME IN.
OKAY, SO WE'LL START FROM HERE,
AND TURN AROUND
AND WALK DOWN THAT WAY AND THEN
WALK BACK TOWARDS US.
♪♪
JUST TURN, COME BACK.
BABY PHAT, I DIDN'T THINK
I DID A GOOD JOB.
I'M ALWAYS TOLD
THAT I WALK LIKE A MAN.
IT TAKES YOU ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
OF WARMING UP,
AND THEN YOU COME TOGETHER.
YEAH.
Kimora: OKAY, SHANNON.
Shannon: I WAS MORE EXCITED THAN
NERVOUS, ACTUALLY,
PROBABLY 'CAUSE PRACTICE-- YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU PRACTICE
A LITTLE BIT MORE, YOU GET MORE
CONFIDENT IN YOURSELF.
COME TOGETHER, GIRL,
I AIN'T MAD AT YA.
YEAH.
YOU PULLIN' IT TOGETHER.
OH, YOU PULLING IT TOGETHER,
OKAY.
THAT'S VERY NICE, SHANNON,
YOU'VE BEEN PRACTICING.
PRACTICE MAKES PERFECT.
Kimora: HI, ELYSE.
Elyse: HI.
Kimora: YOU START HERE AND GO
ALL THE WAY TO THE END
AND COME ALL THE WAY BACK LIKE
YOU DID.
YOU GUYS ARE WALKING BETTER THAN
ME, HONEY,
AND IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
DON'T BE NERVOUS.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
OH, MY GOD, HOW LONG HAVE WE
BEEN TOGETHER?
YOU'RE NERVOUS, GIRL.
RELAX YOUR FINGERS.
'CAUSE YOU WALK LIKE YOU HAVE
DIRTY NAPKINS OR TISSUES.
THAT'S ME, I ALWAYS HAVE...
IT'S NOT SEXY.
Kimora: YOU ALL DID VERY WELL.
I WAS VERY, VERY IMPRESSED.
BYE, YOU GUYS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU GUYS WERE WONDERFUL.
Shannon: THANKS.
♪♪
WE HAVE MAIL!
I LOVE GETTING MAIL.
Adrianne: WHO WANTS TO READ IT?
ELYSE?
"TWO OF YOU WILL CONTINUE ON TO
BECOME AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Adrianne: ISN'T THAT WEIRD?
REMEMBER WHEN IT SAID
"NINE OF YOU"?
Shannon: YEAH.
Adrianne: NOW IT SAYS TWO.
I THINK I DESERVE IT BECAUSE
I CAME A REALLY LONG WAY SINCE I
CAME HERE.
I'VE JUST TRIED TO DO MY BEST
EVERY TIME WE DO ANYTHING.
Shannon: WHEN YOU GIVE SOMETHING
LIKE YOUR BEST,
YOU JUST GIVE YOUR ALL AND YOU
FEEL LIKE
YOU SHOULD BE REWARDED FOR THAT.
Elyse: I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S
ACCEPTABLE TO SAY
THAT ANYONE DESERVES TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
IT'S REALLY NOT A BASIC HUMAN
RIGHT TO, UM,
GET A MODELING CONTRACT.
♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
TONIGHT IS A SPECIAL ELIMINATION
BECAUSE TONIGHT
THERE WILL ONLY BE TWO GIRLS
LEFT STANDING,
AND THOSE TWO GIRLS WILL COMPETE
IN A BABY PHAT FASHION SHOW.
YOUR PERFORMANCE IN THAT FASHION
SHOW WILL HELP DETERMINE
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW AS USUAL, WE HAVE OUR PANEL
OF CRAZY-ASS JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS THE ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS.
WE HAVE BEAU QUILLIAN.
BEAU IS A FASHION EDITOR AT
"MARIE CLAIRE."
WE HAVE KIMORA LEE SIMMONS.
KIMORA IS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
AND OWNER OF BABY PHAT FASHIONS.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST, WE HAVE
A SPECIAL JUDGE-- DREW LINEHAN.
DREW'S A FASHION SHOW CASTING
DIRECTOR AND A PRODUCER.
WE'LL BRING YOU IN ONE BY ONE
FOR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND, ELYSE, YOU'RE FIRST.
OKAY.
JUST SHOW US, YOU KNOW,
WHAT YOU THINK YOU'VE LEARNED IN
TERMS OF POSING.
♪♪
Tyra: THANK YOU.
Drew: SO, ELYSE,
WHAT DROVE YOU TO THIS?
I TRIED OUT FOR THIS ON
JUST A TOTAL WHIM.
THEY HAD THE AUDITION AT THIS
SILLY LITTLE PLACE.
IT WAS RIGHT BY MY HOUSE, AND,
LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I JUST-- I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE FUN.
WHAT REALLY HAVE YOU LEARNED?
WHERE DO YOU THINK YOU'VE
PROGRESSED
FROM WHERE YOU STARTED?
Elyse: THE FIRST THING I LEARNED
WAS JUST TO BE CONFIDENT AND TO
STOP THINKING
OF MYSELF AS A NERD, TO BE A
MODEL INSIDE.
IT WAS REALLY HARD FOR ME TO
ACCEPT CRITICISM,
LIKE, ON A PHYSICAL BASIS, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE I COME FROM THIS,
LIKE, TOTALLY INTELLECTUAL,
MENTAL WORLD.
Tyra: EARLY ON, YOU WERE LIKE,
BEING A TOP MODEL IS JUST
STRICTLY PHYSICAL.
YOU SAID THAT MYSELF, CINDY
CRAWFORD, HEIDI KLUM,
OTHER TOP MODELS-- THAT THE ONLY
REASON WHY WE WERE TOP MODELS
IS THAT WE WERE THE BEST
PHYSICALLY LOOKING MODELS
IN THE WORLD,
AND I DISAGREED WITH YOU.
I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T THINK
THERE'S REALLY
A LOT OF MERITS THAT ONE CAN
HAVE OUTSIDE OF THE PHYSICAL,
AND I THINK I HAVE THOSE.
Tyra: YOU DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
OUTSIDE OF THE PHYSICAL THAT
MAKES A SUPERMODEL?
I DON'T THINK SO, NO.
HOW DO YOU FEEL NOW?
I DEFINITELY, UM, I STILL
BELIEVE IN ESTROGEN FEATURES,
AND, YOU KNOW, ALL THAT STUFF.
WHY DON'T YOU BREAK THAT DOWN
FOR US?
Janice: WHAT'S THAT?
Elyse: IF YOU'VE HAD A LOT OF
ESTROGEN IN YOUR DEVELOPMENT,
IT CREATES A CERTAIN SORT OF
FACIAL FEATURES,
AND THAT'S A SMALL JAW,
WIDER-SET EYES, BIGGER LIPS,
SMALLER EARS,
A SMALLER BROW RIDGE.
SO IF YOU GAVE A MALE MODEL
ESTROGEN...
Elyse: NO, YOU'D HAVE TO DO IT
WHEN HE WAS, LIKE, AN INFANT.
Janice: WAY OVER MY HEAD,
SORRY, YOU GUYS.
Kimora: ARE YOU PROPOSING THAT I
SHOULD GIVE MY BABY HORMONES?
Elyse: DON'T DO IT.
NO, I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD DO
IT, BUT IT WOULD WORK.
Tyra: SO YOU THINK BEAUTY IS,
UM, SCIENTIFIC, HORMONAL?
Elyse: I THINK A LOT
OF PHYSICAL BEAUTY IS.
SEND ADRIANNE IN, PLEASE.
Beau: IT'S OPERATION
ADRIANNE STORM.
Janice: I DIG IT.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, ADRIANNE, THINK
ABOUT THESE LAST EIGHT WEEKS
AND WHAT YOU'VE LEARNED
IN TERMS OF A PHOTO SHOOT.
♪♪
Tyra: OKAY.
WHY DO YOU WANNA BE A MODEL?
I LOVE BEING THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION.
IT MAKES ME-- OH, I CAN'T SAY
THAT.
Tyra: WHAT?
Adrianne: IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE
GOD.
IT SORT OF IS, ISN'T IT?
YOU THINK YOU'RE READY TO DO
A REAL FASHION SHOW?
LIKE A BIG FASHION SHOW WITH THE
BIGGEST MODELS IN THE WORLD
IN FRONT OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE?
WITH CUTTHROAT MODELS TRYING TO
KNOCK YOU OFF THE RUNWAY?
WITH ALL OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
EDITORS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS, BUYERS?
Janice: IN THE FRONT ROW?
Adrianne: I WOULDN'T BE NERVOUS
AT ALL WITH PEOPLE.
I'M REALLY NOT, I MEAN--
Tyra: IN 4-INCH STILETTOS?
Adrianne: NO, NOT REALLY.
I CAN RUN IN 4-INCH STILETTOS.
Janice: COOL.
Beau: I WOULD JUST SAY ONE
LITTLE THING.
WHEN YOU DO THE, UM, YOU HAVE--
YOU DO YOUR, LIKE, GOOFY SMILE
LIKE...
DON'T DO THAT.
Adrianne: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
Tyra: OH, THIS ONE.
Janice:: I LIKE THE GOOFY SMILE.
I THINK IT'S CUTE.
Adrianne: BYE, GUYS.
Tyra: MISS SHANNON COMING IN
HERE, LOOKING LIKE A REAL MODEL.
Shannon: I'M TRYIN'.
Janice: GUESS WHAT, TYRA.
HER HAIR IS SLICKED BACK, HELLO!
Tyra: FIRST THING I SAW.
LOOKS REALLY PRETTY BACK.
Shannon: THANK YOU.
MAKES YOUR NECK VERY LONG.
Tyra: I WANT YOU TO WORK ABOUT
THREE POSES OF YOUR FACE.
♪♪
TOOTHPASTE COMPANIES OUT THERE,
THIS IS YOUR GIRL.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
CAN YOU NAME THREE PHOTOGRAPHERS
WHO SHOOT FASHION SPREADS
FOR "VOGUE" MAGAZINE?
Shannon: I'M SORRY, I CAN'T.
WHAT ABOUT SOMEBODY YOU'VE
WORKED WITH?
(squealing)
OH, MY GOSH.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE INDUSTRY IF
YOU WANNA BE A TOP MODEL.
Drew: DO YOU KNOW YOUR
MEASUREMENTS?
NO, I DON'T.
Tyra: YOU SHOULD KNOW YOUR REAL
MEASUREMENTS.
AND YOU SHOULD KNOW YOUR FAKE
Kimora: WHAT YOU SAY!
Tyra: YOU KNOW, THERE'S THE FAKE
ONES TO GIVE TO THE CLIENTS
AND THEN THERE'S THE REAL ONES
WHEN YOU'RE DOING,
LIKE, THE MEASUREMENT.
OKAY, SHANNON.
Kimora: THANK YOU.
THANKS, SHANNON.
Shannon: THANK YOU.
Tyra: START WITH ELYSE.
Kimora: ELYSE CAME OFF LIKE A
BIG KNOW-IT-ALL TODAY.
IT COULD WORK FOR HER OR IT
COULD WORK AGAINST HER.
ONCE SHE GETS OUT THERE IN THE
FIELD,
SHE'LL FIND OUT REAL FAST.
Tyra: I LOVE ELYSE'S
INTELLIGENCE,
BUT SHE COMES OFF REALLY EDGY.
SOMETIMES TO BE A TOP MODEL, YOU
NEED TO BE EDGY AND COMMERCIAL.
Drew: I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
SUPERIORITY, BUT SHE REALLY IS,
OBVIOUSLY, THE MOST HIGH FASHION
OUT OF THE GROUP.
Tyra: I'M JUST TORN BECAUSE THE
TITLE OF THE SHOW
AND WHAT THE MEANING OF THE SHOW
IS "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL" IS
NOT JUST BEING
A HIGH-FASHION MODEL.
SHE'S MORE
OF A COMMERCIAL MODEL.
SHE DOES "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED,"
SHE DOES VICTORIA SECRET,
REVLON ADS.
DREW, I'M NOT SURE
SHE HAS THE COMMITMENT.
MEAN, COME ON, SHE FEEL ASLEEP
WHILE YOU WERE TALKING TO HER.
Beau: OUT.
Janice: IN!
Tyra: THIS IS-- ADRIANNE IS
INTERESTING TO ME
BECAUSE WHEN SHE FIRST WALKED
INTO THE SEMI-FINALS
IN LOS ANGELES, LIKE, SHE WAS
NOT A LOOKER.
Janice: SHE DIDN'T WALK,
SHE HOOFED.
Tyra: I MEAN, LOOK AT THAT.
I REALLY ADMIRE HER
TRANSFORMATION.
Beau: THE CAMERA LOVES HER,
SO I WOULDN'T EVER HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WORKING WITH HER.
I'M NOT SO SURE.
SHE DOESN'T REALLY SELL ME.
ADRIANNE'S IN.
OUT.
Janice: (sighing) I'M DYIN'.
Tyra: I THINK SHANNON'S THE ONLY
ONE THAT I CAN SEE
BEING ON THE COUCH OF JAY LENO
OR DAVID LETTERMAN OR--
NO, NOT KNOWING THE
PHOTOGRAPHERS
IS SORT OF NOT ACCEPTABLE.
Beau: YOU KNOW, I DO THINK THAT
THE CAMERA...
LOVES HER FACE.
Tyra: YOU CAN TAKE A COMMERCIAL
GIRL
AND MAKE HER MORE HIGH FASHION.
I JUST DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
POSSIBLE TO DO THAT
IN A COUPLE OF DAYS, 'CAUSE
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE LEFT.
I HATE THESE CUTS!
THEY DRIVE ME CRAZY!
Tyra: IT WILL BE INCREDIBLY HARD
TO SAY GOODBYE
TO ONE OF YOU TONIGHT.
WE'VE ALL BEEN TOGETHER
A VERY LONG TIME.
WE'VE BEEN AROUND THE WORLD
AND BACK AGAIN.
THERE ARE THREE OF YOU LEFT.
THREE BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT ONLY TWO OF YOU ARE STILL IN
THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
HOW BAD DO YOU WANT THIS?
HOW BAD DO YOU WANT THIS,
ADRIANNE?
REAL DAMN BAD, TYRA BANKS.
IT'S JUST BEEN A LONG, STRANGE
TRIP, AND IF I WIN, HELL, YEAH.
SHANNON?
WORDS CANNOT EXPRESS
HOW BAD I WANT THIS.
I'M NERVOUS AND EXCITED.
I'M HAVING THE MINDSET THAT I
REALLY, REALLY, REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY WANNA STAY HERE, BUT
THEN, LIKE,
WHEN THEY'RE CALLING EACH
OTHER'S NAMES,
YOU HAVE TO GET YOURSELF
PREPARED, BECAUSE YOU DON'T
WANNA BE HEARTBROKEN IF YOU ARE
ONE OF THE GIRLS TO LEAVE.
ELYSE?
DAMN BAD, MISS TYRA.
Elyse: AT THIS POINT, I DON'T
HAVE ANY PREDICTIONS
AS TO WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED,
BUT SHANNON DID TELL ME
THAT JESUS TOLD HER THAT I WOULD
BE STAYING HERE SO
THAT MAKES ME FEEL PRETTY
COMFORTABLE.
TONIGHT'S ELIMINATION WILL
DETERMINE WHICH TWO GIRLS
WILL VIE FOR THE TITLE OF
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
AT A FINAL HUGE FASHION SHOW
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
SHANNON.
Tyra: SHANNON,
IF YOU WANT THIS BAD,
YOU HAVE TO STUDY BAD.
YOU HAVE TO LIVE AND BREATHE
THIS INDUSTRY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
WILL ELYSE AND ADRIANNE PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
Adrianne: THAT REALLY SUCKED.
I DIDN'T LIKE GOING UP AGAINST
ELYSE.
I ALWAYS TOLD MYSELF
IF ELYSE AND I
EVER WENT UP AGAINST EACH OTHER,
THAT SHE WOULD BE THE ONE WHO
WOULD GET CHOSEN.
Elyse: ADRIANNE'S DEFINITELY MY
CLOSEST ALLY IN THE HOUSE,
BUT I THINK THAT ADRIANNE IS
REALLY EXPECTING TO WIN.
ADRIANNE, I KNOW THE PANEL HAS
REALLY STAYED
ON TOP OF YOU ABOUT YOUR SPEECH.
SPEECH IS SO IMPORTANT, SO WORK
ON THAT EVEN MORE.
ELYSE...
ELYSE, YOUR LOOK IS REALLY
STRONG FOR THE FASHION WORLD,
FOR THE HARD-CORE, DIE-HARD
FASHION WORLD.
BUT IN ORDER TO BE A MORE
COMMERCIAL MODEL,
A MODEL THAT APPEALS TO THE
MASSES OF AMERICA,
YOU'VE GOTTA SOFTEN UP YOUR LOOK
A LITTLE BIT.
ELYSE, I ADMIRE YOUR
INTELLIGENCE.
I THINK YOU ARE SO SMART.
BUT ONE THING WITH THAT
INTELLIGENCE IS
IT CAN INTIMIDATE PEOPLE,
AND THERE'S A WAY TO USE THAT
INTELLIGENCE IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
MAYBE PUTTING DOWN OTHER PEOPLE
OR SOUNDING DEROGATORY.
ADRIANNE, CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Adrianne: THANK YOU.
Elyse: TYRA TOLD ME THAT I WAS
ARROGANT AND CONDESCENDING
IN MY SPEECH AND IN MY
INTERACTIONS WITH OTHERS
AND I THINK...
SHE WAS RIGHT.
I CAN'T SAY THAT IT FEELS GOOD
TO BE ELIMINATED,
BUT I ALSO CAN'T DENY THAT
THERE'S A CERTAIN
SENSE OF RELIEF THAT COMES
WITH IT.
YOU KNOW,
IT SUCKS TO LOSE AT ANYTHING,
BUT THE DECISION
HAS BEEN MADE FOR ME,
AND I'LL BE A DOCTOR
AND NOT A TOP MODEL.
Tyra: THIS IS THE REAL DEAL NOW.
Janice: THIS IS IT.
Tyra: THIS IS NO JOKE,
THIS IS REAL.
Janice: NO KIDDING.
Elyse: COMING INTO THIS WORLD OF
MODELING WAS THE RESULT
OF A BIZARRE CHAIN OF EVENTS
THAT I CAN ONLY DESCRIBE
AS FLUKEY IN EVERY
SENSE OF THE WORD,
SO WHEN I LEAVE,
I'LL BE GONE FOREVER.
♪♪
Shannon: HI.
WE NEED SOME HELP
ON OUR HAIR, I GUESS.
Shannon: WE'RE GONNA BE IN A
FASHION SHOW TOMORROW.
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS.
I COULDN'T SLEEP LAST NIGHT.
IT WAS A WEIRD MIXTURE OF
OVERJOYNESS AND BEING UPSET.
I WOULD THINK I WOULD GO HOME UP
AGAINST ELYSE, JUST BECAUSE
SHE'S A GENIUS,
AND I'M A HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUT.
Antekqua:
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
WE ARE READY.
BYE, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Adrianne: LATER, ANTEKQUA.
Shannon: "TONIGHT WE WILL BE
HAVING DINNER AT BLUE FIN.
PLEASE BE READY AT 7:00 P.M.
TYRA!
NOT EVEN 20 MINUTES TO GET
READY.
CAN I USE THIS FOR TWO SECONDS?
NO.
COME ON, HAIR, WORK WITH ME.
Tyra: HEY!
Adrianne: HEY.
Shannon: HI!
Tyra: I THOUGHT THE GIRLS WOULD
BE REALLY NERVOUS
THE NIGHT BEFORE THE BABY PHAT
FASHION SHOW,
SO I INVITED THEM TO A SWANKY
DINNER
WITH MAKEUP MAESTRO JAY MANUEL
AND RUNWAY DIVA J. ALEXANDER
Jay: YOU KNOW, REALLY, IT'S GOOD
TO BE SURPRISED.
SERIOUSLY, SHANNON.
SHE'S NEVER HAD SUSHI BEFORE.
Adrianne: I JUST ATE, LIKE--
Shannon: YOU LIKE IT?
OH, SHOOT.
Tyra: WHEN YOU FIRST CAME IN AND
YOU SAW THE TEN GIRLS,
WHO DID YOU THINK WOULD HAVE
BEEN YOUR MOST COMPETITION?
Shannon: WHEN I SAW TESSA LEAVE,
I WAS JUST LIKE, OH, MY WORD.
Tyra: SO WHAT WAS THE TOUGHEST
PART OF BEING IN THE PENTHOUSE?
Adrianne: LIVING WITH KATIE
THE ENTIRE TIME.
Tyra: WHY DO YOU HATE KATIE?
Adrianne: KATIE DID
NOT LIKE ME, MAN.
Tyra: WHY NOT?
Adrianne: I FELT LIKE SHE
THOUGHT I WAS REALLY GHETTO.
WELL...
Jay: WELL, WE KNOW WHO REALLY
EXPECTED
TO BE ONE OF THE LAST TWO--
NICOLE.
Tyra: OH, NICOLE.
Jay: SHE WAS REALLY CONFIDENT.
Adrianne: I THINK SHE'S JUST
VERY USED
TO ALWAYS GETTING HER WAY.
AND WHAT ABOUT EBONY?
Adrianne: EBONY,
YOU BETTER WORK IT, GIRL.
I NEED SOME MOISTURIZER,
SHE WAS COOL.
SHE TOLD ME I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
HER ESSENCE.
THE ESSENCE.
EVEN THOUGH GISELLE COULD BE
ANNOYING SOMETIMES,
WHEN SHE WASN'T,
SHE WAS ACTUALLY COOL.
WHEN KESSE LEFT, I FELT LIKE
DOWN
JUST BECAUSE I LIKED HER A LOT.
Shannon: JUST HAD, LIKE, THIS
FREE PERSONALITY.
LIKE, REALLY, WHAT LIT HER UP
WAS, LIKE, GOING OUT DANCING
OR GOING OUT TO EAT.
SHE JUST, LIKE,
TOTALLY SPARKED UP.
Adrianne: BUT THE ONE THAT I
REALLY HONESTLY DID NOT LIKE
WAS SOMEONE WHO I THOUGHT WAS
VERY, VERY, VERY FAKE
WHEN I FINALLY FOUND OUT WHO
THEY WERE, AND THAT WAS ROBIN.
SHE WAS AWFUL TO ME AT THE END.
AS OPPOSED WITH HER, WHO
BELIEVES IN GOD AND STUFF
AND ACTUALLY ACTS LIKE A DECENT
HUMAN BEING.
I WANNA SEE SOME WALKIN',
AND I'M GONNA DO SOME DOUBLES
WITH Y'ALL.
♪♪
Tyra: WHOO!
WHOO!
ALL RIGHT, Y'ALL, LET'S DO WHAT
THE SACRAMENTO KINGS DO.
OKAY, YOU GOTTA GO, UHH!
YOUR LIVES ARE GONNA BE CHANGED
FOREVER TOMORROW.
UHH!
(laughing)
SHOOT, MAN, I'M STUFFED,
I HAD SO MUCH FOOD.
(Adrianne belches)
I REALLY ADMIRE THAT SHE DOESN'T
CARE WHAT ANYONE THINKS OF HER.
SHE'S HERSELF NO MATTER WHAT.
LOOK AT THAT ZIT.
THAT ZIT NEEDS TO GO BEFORE
TOMORROW.
THAT'S A BIG WHOPPER.
Shannon: POP IT.
Adrianne: EW!
Shannon: YOU WANT ME TO POP IT
FOR YA?
Adrianne: NO.
Shannon: I SWEAR IT'LL GO DOWN.
Adrianne: IT'S PAINFUL.
Shannon: I'LL POP IT.
Adrianne: NO!
Shannon: PLEASE?
Adrianne: DON'T, GROSS.
I'VE REALLY ENJOYED OUR PAST
COUPLE OF DAYS TOGETHER.
WE'RE COMPLETE OPPOSITES, BUT AT
LEAST SHE DOESN'T MAKE ME
FEEL LIKE -- FOR BEING WHO I AM.
GOOD NIGHT, SHANNON.
Shannon: GOOD NIGHT.
'CAUSE TOMORROW WE FIGHT TO THE
DEATH.
♪♪
Kimora: SO YOU'RE HERE TODAY TO
DO A FITTING
FOR THE SHOW THAT'S TONIGHT, AND
IT'S A HIGH RUNWAY, LONG RUNWAY,
LOUD MUSIC, LOTS OF PEOPLE,
POLITICIANS, MUSICIANS,
RAPPERS, ROCKERS, EVERYTHING.
SO... READY?
YES.
Kimora: IS THIS SNUG ON YOU?
Adrianne: MMM.
THESE THINGS LOOK VERY FULL ON
YOU.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
Kimora: YOU'RE VERY THIN.
Shannon: YEAH.
NOW I GUESS YOU HAVE TO DO A
LITTLE HAIR, A LITTLE MAKEUP,
AND I'LL SEE YOU BACK AT THE
SPOT IN A LITTLE WHILE.
Shannon: OKAY.
♪♪
Adrianne: I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS,
BUT I'VE GONE SO FAR.
I'VE DONE SO MUCH HERE, AND I
WOULDN'T TRADE THIS EXPERIENCE
FOR ANYTHING IN THE WORLD.
Shannon: IT'S JUST VERY,
VERY NERVE-RACKING.
I'M SO NERVOUS, I HAVE GOOSE
BUMPS RIGHT NOW.
WHEN WE FIRST ARRIVED, WE WALKED
IN, AND WE HAD, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
PASSES AROUND OUR NECK, AND THAT
JUST MAKES YOU FEEL COOL.
THE ENERGY WAS VERY FAST-PACED,
VERY HECTIC.
Tyra: SEE, YOUR MAKEUP LOOKS
GORGEOUS.
Shannon: YOU GOT, LIKE, PEOPLE
DOING MY MAKEUP, AND IT WAS
JUST, LIKE, YOU KNOW, FAST,
BUT I ENJOYED IT.
Tyra: REMEMBER, CHIN DOWN.
RELAX THE SHOULDERS.
Adrianne: YEAH, RELAX THE
SHOULDERS.
Tyra: I'LL BE YELLING AT YOU ON
THE RUNWAY FOR DOING IT, OKAY?
Shannon: I WON'T.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT.
Adrianne: I DON'T
LIKE TO BE NERVOUS.
I WANNA BUST MY BALLS AND GET
THIS.
BEFORE WE WENT ON, I PEERED OUT
IN THE BIG TENT,
WHICH THE SHOW WAS HELD.
IT WAS AWESOME.
THERE WAS A LOT OF PEOPLE.
Tyra: THERE'S NO RETOUCHING ON
THE RUNWAY.
THERE'S NO ROOM FOR MISTAKES.
HOPEFULLY, IT WAS FIERCE.
HOPEFULLY, IT WAS PERFECT.
AND IF IT WASN'T, THE WHOLE ROOM
AND THE WHOLE WORLD
JUST SAW YOU SCREW UP.
♪♪
(applause)
WHOO!
BEING ON THAT STAGE WITH THOSE
LIGHTS-- OH!
IT JUST, LIKE, TRANSFORMED ME.
LIKE, I WAS ON CLOUD NINE.
♪ NEVER DOUBT NO DOUBT
WHAT IT IS WHERE IT'S AT ♪
♪ WHAT IT'S ABOUT TRUDGING
THROUGH THE UNDERGROUND ♪
♪ NO ONE'S HERE
TO MAP IT ALL OUT ♪
♪ BEFORE YOU BLACK OUT
PULLING YOU OUT OF THE MIST ♪
♪ BRINGIN' YOU BACK TO THE
TRUENESS NEVER DOUBT NO DOUBT ♪
♪ WHAT IT IS WHERE IT'S AT ♪
THAT'S ADRIANNE!
Adrianne: IT WAS REALLY COOL.
THERE'S SO MUCH LIGHT IN YOUR
FACE,
YOU CAN'T SEE IN THE AUDIENCE IF
YOU WANTED TO.
I JUST SAW SHAPES PASSING ME.
I WAS SOMETHING FIERCE.
♪ THE JERSEY SNEER BEST BEWARE
AND STAND CLEAR ♪
♪ ORIGINAL
SO YOU CAN'T COMPARE ♪
♪ WORD UP TEARING THROUGH THE
PAGES OF RAP... ♪
I THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE A VERY
CLEAR-CUT DECISION,
BUT IT'S PROVED TO BE A LITTLE
BIT HARDER THAN THAT,
AND I THINK THE OUTCOME'S GONNA
BE VERY SURPRISING.
♪ THE WINDS OF CHANGE
HAVE BLOWN ♪♪
♪♪
OH, THEY NEED TO BREATHE!
♪ NEVER DOUBT NO DOUBT
WHAT IT IS WHERE IT'S AT ♪
♪ WHAT IT'S ABOUT TRUDGING
THROUGH THE UNDERGROUND ♪
♪ NO ONE'S HERE
TO MAP IT ALL OUT ♪
♪ BEFORE YOU BLACK OUT
PULLING YOU UP OUT OF THE MIST ♪
♪ BRINGIN' YOU BACK TO THE
TRUENESS NEVER DOUBT NO DOUBT ♪
♪ WHAT IT IS WHERE IT'S AT
WHAT IT'S ABOUT ♪
♪ TRUDGING THROUGH THE
UNDERGROUND ♪
♪ NO ONE'S HERE
TO MAP IT ALL OUT ♪
♪ BEFORE YOU BLACK OUT
PULLING YOU UP OUT OF THE MIST ♪
♪ BRINGIN' YOU BACK TO THE
TRUENESS... ♪
Tyra: I WENT TO THAT FASHION
SHOW THINKING,
"MAYBE THIS ONE WILL WIN."
BUT I'M GOING TO BED TONIGHT
LIKE I DON'T KNOW,
AND I REALLY DON'T.
♪♪
Shannon: TOMORROW IS THE LAST
JUDGING PROCESS.
ARE YOU SCARED?
Shannon: YEAH.
I AM VERY, VERY NERVOUS.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S, LIKE,
FINALLY THE TWO.
I'M TRYING TO, LIKE, REALLY
EMBED THAT IN MY BRAIN--
HEY, I'M IN THE FINAL TWO.
Adrianne: IF I DON'T WIN THIS,
I'M NOT GONNA, LIKE, LET IT,
LIKE, END MY LIFE, BUT I'M
BUSTING MY BALLS
TRYING TO WIN THIS THING.
GOOD NIGHT, SHANNON.
Shannon: GOOD NIGHT.
GOOD LUCK.
Adrianne: GOOD LUCK,
MISS SHANNON.
♪♪
Shannon: I CAME HERE TO WIN,
SO IT WOULD DEFINITELY BE HARD
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW EACH OTHER
AND STUFF,
BUT I WOULD DEFINITELY RATHER
WIN IT THAN HER.
Adrianne: WE'VE BEEN LIVING WITH
EACH OTHER FOR A LONG TIME,
SO IT'S GONNA BE HARD IN BOTH
ASPECTS, YOU KNOW?
SHE'S AN OPPONENT,
YET, SHE'S A BUDDY.
I THINK WE BOTH DESERVE IT, BUT
ONLY ONE OF US IS GONNA GET IT.
WELCOME, LADIES.
HELLO.
YOU ALL LOOK ABSOLUTELY
STUNNING.
SO YOU GUYS EXPERIENCED YOUR
FIRST BIG FASHION SHOW.
YOU WALKED THE CATWALK
FOR BABY PHAT.
THE BABY PHAT FASHION SHOW WAS
YOUR FINAL TEST.
YOUR LIFE IS GOING TO CHANGE.
WE TOOK INTO ACCOUNT BOTH YOUR
PERFORMANCES LAST NIGHT
AS WELL AS ALL OF YOUR WORK IN
THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS
IN DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE A REVLON
CONTRACT,
A CONTRACT WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
WILHELMINA MODELS, INC.
AND A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE."
NOW I KNOW YOU'RE USED TO US
HAVING A SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE
EVERY WEEK,
BUT THIS WEEK I'VE DECIDED TO
ONLY HAVE US FOUR.
WE'VE KNOWN YOU FROM DAY ONE.
WE KNOW YOUR INS AND OUTS.
WE KNOW YOUR STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES, WHAT YOU EXCEL AT,
AND WHAT YOU STILL ARE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH.
WE KNOW YOU.
YOU BOTH HAVE EXPERIENCED
A LOT OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PHOTO SHOOTS,
AND I HAVE PERSONALLY CHOSEN
WHAT I THINK
ARE YOUR STRONGEST PICTURES.
AND WE'LL START WITH SHANNON.
♪♪
Tyra: THAT WAS A LITTLE FREAKY.
Janice: I LOVE THE LOOK AND THE
INTENT IN SHANNON'S EYES.
THIS, TO ME, IS HIGH FASHION.
YOU ROCK HERE.
♪♪
Beau: I LIKE THIS ONE BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT
TO SEE SHANNON GIVE SOME KIND
OF SEX APPEAL.
♪♪
Kimora: WELL, I THINK YOU LOOK
A LITTLE THIN IN SWIMWEAR.
YOU WERE LOOKING
VERY APPLE PIE TO ME.
IT'S NOT ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
Janice: WHOA.
Tyra: WITH THIS ONE, I WAS PROUD
OF YOU
FOR BRINGING A LITTLE SEXUALITY
INTO MISS CLEAN LADY.
MISS INNOCENT IS NOT SO INNOCENT
IN THAT PICTURE.
ALL RIGHT, ADRIENNE, NOW HERE
ARE YOUR BEST SHOTS.
♪♪
Tyra: ADRIANNE, I LOVE THIS SHOT
OF YOU.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU WERE SO
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT SNAKE.
I MEAN, EVEN WHEN IT WAS KIND OF
STARTING TO STRANGLE YOU,
YOU WERE STILL LIKE, "IT'S KINDA
TRYING TO KILL ME,
BUT I'M GONNA GET MY SHOT."
AND I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT YOU WERE SO STRONG
AND CONFIDENT WITH IT.
Janice: I LOVE THIS PICTURE.
I WISH THAT YOU HADN'T PUT THE
FOOT IN FRONT OF THE LEG.
IT FEATURES THE FOOT, WHICH
MAKES IT LOOK LARGER THAN LIFE,
LIKE A PADDLE, OR YOU KNOW,
REALLY BIG HAUNCHES.
UH, BUT YOUR FACE ROCKS.
Beau: THIS I REALLY LOVED AND I
THOUGHT YOU WERE WELL SUITED
FOR THIS SHOOT IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE A KIND
OF ATHLETIC BUILD,
AND THIS REALLY SHOWS IT.
IT'S A GREAT PHOTO.
Janice: BOY, I'LL SAY.
Kimora: I THINK THAT IT'S NICE
TO SEE, UM,
A SEXY VERSION OF TOMBOY YOU.
Janice: YEAH.
Tyra: I LOVE THIS PICTURE,
THIS LOOKS LIKE AN AD.
I THINK YOU LOOK AMAZING, AND I
ADMIRE YOUR COURAGE
TO HAVE YOURSELF HANGING OUT
LIKE THAT, BUT NOT HANGING OUT.
Beau: I WISH WE HAD ONE OF
SHANNON FROM THAT SHOOT.
Janice: YEAH!
Kimora: DO YOU HAVE ANY WORDS,
ANYTHING TO SAY?
Shannon: I MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
PERFECT ON EVERYTHING,
BUT I TRIED TO LEARN AND TRIED
TO GET BETTER WITH--
I'M ALWAYS READY TO LEARN.
AND I CAN BECOME THAT
SUPERMODEL.
I GOT IT IN ME SO...
Kimora: ADRIANNE?
Adrianne: I JUST WANNA SAY THIS
HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE BEST EXPERIENCES OF
MY LIFE.
I FOUND OUT I CAN BE MORE THAN
JUST A WOMAN.
I CAN BE A SEX MACHINE IN A LOT
OF MY PICTURES,
AND IT'S REALLY, REALLY COOL
BECAUSE IT REALLY
CONTRASTS WHAT I AM AT HOME.
I'M REALLY PROUD THAT I CAN BE
THAT WOMAN.
Janice: YOU GIRLS HAVE GROWN
LEAPS AND BOUNDS.
IT'S JUST AMAZING.
WE'RE ALL SO PROUD OF YOU.
Tyra: OKAY, SHANNON, ADRIANNE,
THE JUDGES WILL NOW DELIBERATE,
AND I'LL JUST LET YOU KNOW
HONESTLY,
I WOKE UP THIS MORNING
NOT KNOWING WHO I WANTED.
OKAY, WE'LL SEE YOU IN A BIT.
THANKS.
ALL RIGHT, JUDGES, LET'S
DELIBERATE.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT SHANNON BLEW
ME AWAY LAST NIGHT
WITH HER PERFORMANCE.
ADRIANNE STILL WALKED DOWN THE
RUNWAY
LIKE SHE HAD A BROOMSTICK SHOVED
UP HER ASS.
Kimora: SHANNON KICKED
ADRIANNE'S BUTT.
THAT SMILE THAT USUALLY KILLS
ME-- I DIDN'T SEE IT.
Janice: I'M GOING TO TAKE OFF,
YOU KNOW, MY NEGATIVE REMARKS
BEFORE ABOUT HER NOT DOING THE
NUDE SHOOT, BIG DEAL.
SHE MORPHED INTO A MODEL.
Tyra: IT'S INTERESTING, JANICE,
BECAUSE
WHEN I WOKE UP THIS MORNING, I
WAS LIKE,
JANICE HAS MADE UP A DECISION.
I KNOW SHE'S GONNA COME IN THERE
AND BE GUNNING FOR ADRIANNE,
SO I'M LOOKING AT JANICE LIKE,
WOW, YOU CHANGED YOUR MIND.
I'M GONNA BE THE VOICE OF
DISSENT.
(chuckling)
I LIKED ADRIANNE THE BEST LAST
NIGHT.
I FELT LIKE ADRIANNE HAD HER OWN
KIND OF A WALK.
I FEEL LIKE SHANNON WAS TRYING
TO DO AN IMITATION OF A MODEL,
WHEREAS ADRIANNE WAS JUST KIND
OF MORE HERSELF,
AND I SAW KIND OF MORE POTENTIAL
IN ADRIANNE TO DEVELOP, LIKE,
A VERY KIND OF STRONG WALK
THAT'S VERY MUCH HER OWN.
Kimora: I THINK THAT AS A
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN,
I THINK THAT ADRIANNE IS A MORE
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN.
LIKE, WHEN I'M LOOKING AT THEM
TODAY,
SHANNON LOOKS REALLY,
REALLY COMMERCIAL.
FASHION THESE DAYS
IS SO MUCH EDGIER.
IT'S NOT COMMERCIAL.
Tyra: WE DON'T WANT BEAUTY
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
Kimora: RIGHT.
Janice: I THINK SHE'S
REMINISCENT OF GRACE KELLY,
IF YOU WANT.
SHE CAN SELL DIAMONDS.
SHE'S A PRINCESS.
Kimora: SO I HEAR EVERYTHING
YOU'RE SAYING, AND I AGREE,
AND I AGREE, BUT I JUST THINK
THAT MY OPINION IS THAT
ADRIANNE HAS MORE GRIT AND MORE
DEPTH.
Beau: I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
THESE TWO PHOTOGRAPHS,
YOU CAN TELL THAT ADRIANNE'S
LIVED A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THERE'S SOMETHING COOKING BEHIND
ADRIANNE'S EYES.
Kimora: WHO IS GONNA BE ON THAT
TALK SHOW HOST LATE NIGHT COUCH?
SHANNON'S GONNA GO UP THERE AND
BLOW THEM AWAY AND BE ABLE
TO TALK AND BE ELOQUENT,
AND ADRIANNE CAN BE FUNNY,
BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
HEAR HER.
AND I THOUGHT, OKAY, IF WE'RE
DOING SPOKESMODEL,
THEN I GUESS WE HAVE
TO JUST GO BACK TO SHANNON.
WHAT DOES SHANNON REALLY HAVE TO
SAY?
WOULDN'T YOU BE MORE INTERESTED
IN ADRIANNE'S CHARACTER?
CHARACTER, YES,
HOW SHE SOUNDS, NO.
THIS MORNING
I FOUND A SHEET OF PAPER.
IT WAS A LIST OF MY 20
SEMI-FINALISTS IN L.A.,
AND I HAD MY NOTES
FOR EVERY GIRL.
AND I JUST WENT DOWN, AND I SAW
ADRIANNE'S NAME.
I DIDN'T HAVE
ONE COMMENT ABOUT HER.
THE ONLY THING I HAD NEXT TO HER
NAME
WAS A BIG, FAT "N-O" WITH AN
EXCLAMATION MARK.
Janice: SEE? YOU NEVER KNOW.
AND IT IS FREAKING ME OUT THAT
SHE IS A FINALIST,
AND I'M STUCK HERE, LIKE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL TO DO.
Kimora: AND JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY,
WHAT DID YOU HAVE NEXT TO
SHANNON?
Tyra: "MISS APPLE PIE."
VERY COMMERCIAL, VERY SELLABLE.
Janice: SHE WAS DOPE LAST NIGHT.
Kimora: SHE WAS DOPE LAST NIGHT.
I'M READY TO MAKE MY DECISION.
ME TOO.
Tyra: WOULD ADRIANNE AND SHANNON
COME IN, PLEASE?
HI, GIRLS.
HI.
Tyra: LET ME REMIND YOU WHAT'S
AT STAKE.
A CONTRACT WITH REVLON,
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "MARIE CLAIRE" MAGAZINE
AND REPRESENTATION BY TOP
MODELING AGENCY WILHELMINA.
THE JUDGES
HAVE REACHED A DECISION.
ONE OF YOU IS ABOUT TO BE A STAR
IN A MATTER OF MINUTES.
YOUR LIFE IS GOING TO CHANGE.
THE WINNER'S PICTURE
IS HANGING BEHIND ME.
AND WHEN THE CLOTH IS DROPPED,
IT WILL REVEAL WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ADRIANNE, YOU HAVE TRANSFORMED
LIKE CINDERELLA.
WHEN I LOOKED AT YOU IN L.A.
IN OUR SEMI-FINALS, I WAS LIKE,
"I DON'T EVEN THINK SHE'LL MAKE
IT TO THE FINALS."
THEN YOU GOT HERE,
FIRST WEEK, I WAS LIKE,
"I DON'T THINK SHE'LL MAKE IT TO
THE SECOND WEEK,"
AND YOU'RE STANDING HERE.
SHANNON, YOU HAD A LOOK THAT ALL
THE JUDGES
THOUGHT WAS SO COMMERCIAL,
SO SAFE.
SOME OF US SAID,
A BORING LOOK.
BUT YOU WALKED THAT RUNWAY
LAST NIGHT LIKE A DIVA.
YOU STOLE THAT SHOW,
THAT SHOW WAS YOURS.
THE DECISION IS MADE.
AND AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL IS:
ADRIANNE.
YES!
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU GOT IT, GIRL.
Adrianne: I WASN'T EXPECTING TO
SEE MY FACE UP THERE AT ALL.
Shannon: I CAME HERE TO WIN, AND
I DIDN'T,
BUT I'M ALSO PLEASED BECAUSE I
MADE IT THIS FAR,
AND A LOT OF GIRLS WOULD
DEFINITELY WANNA BE
IN MY POSITION, AND THEY'RE NOT.
Janice: WAY TO GO, GIRL.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
Adrianne: COME HERE, MISS TYRA.
(laughing)
Tyra: GIVE ME ONE OF THESE.
AAH!
Tyra: ADRIANNE ENDED UP
PREVAILING
BECAUSE SHE HAS AN EDGINESS.
SHE HAS A BEAUTY THAT IS
UNDENIABLE
AND A PERSONALITY THAT IS SO
DYNAMIC.
ADRIANNE IS NOW,
AND ADRIANNE IS THE FUTURE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO FEEL.
I FEEL I LOVE JANICE DICKINSON.
WELL, I DIDN'T VOTE FOR YOU.
Tyra: I'M PROUD OF YOU,
ADRIANNE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU WERE THE BIGGEST
TRANSFORMATION,
AND YOU DID IT, GIRL!
NO MORE WAITRESSING IN JOLIET!
Adrianne: SCREW SERVING EVER
AGAIN.
I'M GONNA HAVE A GOOD LIFE NOW.
MY FAMILY'S GONNA HAVE A GOOD
LIFE NOW.
A LOT IS GOING TO CHANGE,
AND IT KICKS SO MUCH ASS.
♪♪
(giggling)
YOU SHUT UP.